PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to Google Cloud Drawing
Board, where we doodle
our way through the cloud.
Today's topic,
what is Cloud SQL?
Cloud SQL is a fully managed
relational database for MySQL,
PostgreSQL, and SQL Server.
It reduces maintenance
cost and automates
database provisioning,
storage capacity management,
replication, and backups.
It offers quick setup, with
standard connection drivers
and built-in migration tools.
Cloud SQL is easy to setup.
You select the
region and zone where
you would like the instance to
be, and it gets created there.
You also have a lot of
configuration options,
where you can select
the machine type
with the right number of CPU
and amount of memory you need.
Choose storage each type between
solid state and hard disk
drives, depending on latency
queries per second and cost
requirements.
And set storage capacity.
Higher storage capacity
leads to better performance.
Cloud SQL also offers automated
backups and recovery options.
You can set time slots
and locations for backups.
For production
applications, it is
recommended to enable
high availability, or HA.
By enabling this feature,
the database instance
will automatically failover to
another zone in your selected
region in case of an outage.
You can also create
cross-regional replicas
to protect from
regional failures.
In addition, you can enable
automatic storage increase
to add more storage
when nearing capacity.
Now, how can you migrate
an existing MySQL database
to Cloud SQL?
Cloud console makes it very
easy by providing a migrate data
button, which guides
you through easy steps.
First, you provide your
data source details,
things like public IP
address, port number,
and your replication
credentials.
Second, you create a
Cloud SQL read replica,
just like we discussed
in the creation process,
using a SQL dump file.
Third, you sync the read
replica with source.
And, finally, you
promote the read replica
to primary instance
with very low downtime.
Is data safe in Cloud SQL?
Well, just like anything
else at Google Cloud,
the data in Cloud
SQL is encrypted
at rest and in transit.
External connections
can be encrypted
using SSL or Cloud
SQL Proxy, which
is a tool to help you connect
to your Cloud SQL instance
from your local machines.
You can use Cloud SQL
as a relational database
for your applications that are
hosted within Google Cloud,
like App Engine, Cloud Run,
Compute Engine, Kubernetes
Engine, or Cloud Functions.
You can also connect
your Cloud SQL database
with applications that are
hosted outside of Google Cloud.
Link for more details
is included below.
Cloud SQL pricing varies
depending on MySQL, PostgreSQL,
or SQL Server.
Broadly speaking, though,
it's the combination
of the type of instance,
storage, or network you use.
SQL Server also has
some licensing costs.
Now, what are some of
the Cloud SQL use cases?
Since Cloud SQL is a
relational database,
you can use it with any
online transaction processing
apps, such as order or
payment processing apps,
where you need to
handle frequent queries
with fast response times.
Want to learn more
about Cloud SQL?
Check out cloud.google.com/sql.